so they say that writing is rewriting
but what does this really mean I mean
how much time should we spend on a first
draft and then how it's time to be spend
rewriting it's a great question because
rewriting is one of the most
misunderstood of all of the major
writing steps partly because of that
famous line that you just stated writing
is rewriting there is no question of
that if you want to write a great piece
of storytelling you're going to have to
do a lot of rewriting but that concept
that writing is rewriting often makes
writers make a huge mistake right at the
beginning which is they think that my
first draft just get it on paper right
to overcome or whatever writing block
just get it down on paper don't try to
be perfect right because that just will
just stop you from writing entirely
right okay so they get the script down
on paper and then they think okay I'll
fix any mistakes in the rewrite except
that they don't fix the mistakes in the
rewrite what people don't realize is
that first draft turns into concrete
when you've actually written it out and
it's on paper in many ways in your mind
it solidifies in such a way that it is
then very difficult difficult to break
that apart and to make the key
structural changes that need to be made
this is why in a lot writers have shot
when I tell them this for most scripts
the second draft is worse than the first
draft and it just gets worse from there
and that is because of the approach that
they take to the script in the first
place because when you write that first
draft some fundamental things are going
to be embedded in that script this is
why it is so important that writers do a
lot of prep work before writing the
first draft starting all the way back
with the premise I
always tell Reuters it is so important
to take a tremendous amount of time
exploring your premise line ticking
weeks to look at just one sentence right
my one line one sentence log line
because you can find a lot of the
inherent structural problems in your
script that you're going to encounter
right there in the first sentence now if
that also means we do a lot of prep work
in creating our characters figuring out
our structure learning the end point of
the story before we begin writing so on
and so forth that doesn't mean that
you're going to again try to make that
first draft perfect what it does mean is
that you're going to be looking at what
are the embedded structural problems in
this story and try to make the fixes
before you actually write the draft and
most of those fixes will occur if you do
your prep work you can get a very good
story in the seam list the scene
sequence now this is in many ways locked
up the writers don't realize what an
important step this is in the writing
process the seamless the scene sequence
because this is the last place before
you actually write scenes to see the
architecture of your story for example
by do a lot of story consulting work and
my preference is don't give me a full
script
give me your scene sequence I can spot
90% of your problems and come up with
the solutions right from the scene
sequence because if I see it as it is
the first draft of a script I've got all
that dialogue I've got a lot of
undergrowth that is hiding the bones of
the story and it's keeping me from
saying what is not working and how it
could be fixed so this is why it's so
important to do your craft homework
before writing the first draft and in
that first
it will then make the rewriting process
so much simpler and it will guarantee
that your second draft is better than
your first draft
one more point about rewriting because
it is so misunderstood most writers
don't understand that rewriting is a set
of tools just like plot character and
soul and one of the key tools about
rewriting is the order that you rewrite
for example most writers the first thing
they fix when they're doing a rewrite is
the dialogue it's the last thing you
should touch when I work with a writer
on a script we don't talk about dialogue
for the until the third or fourth draft
because it's all about getting the story
right and that's what you want to focus
focus on in your rewriting your the
steps of finding the structural problems
and the first step in finding the
structural problems of your script is go
back to the desire line of your story
make sure that you have a good strong
spine you have a desire line that will
track and drive this story from
beginning to end so it's just like
building a house absolutely
you